Land und Brecht
[Musik]
Richard schönen guten Morgen ja schönen
guten Morgen Markus heute mal wieder
persönlich du bist in Hamburg freut mich
sehr immer nett mit dir hier in in
dieser kriminade hier zu sitzen ja
schwer deutlich gemütlich deutlich
gemütlicher freue mich immer dich von
Angesicht zu Angesicht zu sehen Richard
mitten rein nur noch ein paar Wochen ich
habe es kaum mitgekriegt Fußball WM in
Katar
freust du dich das ist eine gute Frage
Markus also eine
Fußball-Weltmeisterschaft in der Wüste
in einem Land in dem
falkenjagdhöhe im Kurs steht also
Fußball in einer Autokratie die
Terrorismus und Kriege finanziert und
die wir nicht zu Hause gucken können
weil da ist zu kalt
die werden auch nicht zusammen gucken
dürfen weil wahrscheinlich neue
corona-maßnahmen kommen hör auf in einer
Gast
haben dass irgendein irrer in Moskau auf
den roten Knopf drücken ja das ist
sozusagen die mengenlage die gasminister
freue so ja und ich finde es ist ehrlich
gesagt eine totale legitime Frage naja
so man könnte natürlich grundsätzlich
sagen Ablenkungen sind in dieser Zeit
herzlich Willkommen zu man kann aber
auch auf der anderen Seite sagen guck
mal ich erinnere mich 1991 januar 1991
Deutschland war seit dem 3 Oktober
wieder Verein der Kalte Krieg schien
überwunden und da begann im Januar 1991
der Überfall Saddam Husseins auf Kuwait
und der sogenannte zweite Golfkrieg
und damals haben wir aus Betroffenheit
mit dem Krieg als Deutscher gesagt das
ist ja fürchterlich wir waren indirekte
Partei wir haben sozusagen das
UNO-Mandat dass sie Amerikaner hatten
unterstützt indem wir finanzielle Hilfe
geleistet haben aber gleichzeitig war in
Deutschland diese Betroffenheit stell
dir vor es ist wirklich wieder Krieg und
wir fanden das so schrecklich weil wir
dachten jetzt ist Schluss mitkriegen und
dass dieser Betroffenheit heraus haben
nicht nur viele weiße Bettlaken aus dem
Fenster gehängt sondern wir haben in
Köln wo ich 30 Jahre gelebt habe den
Karneval ausfallen lassen weil wir
gesagt haben wir können ja kein Karneval
feiern während ein anderer Stelle in der
Welt blutvergossen wird und krieg ist
und wer wenn nicht ich wüsste besser was
das für dich bedeutet eben aber ich war
damals tatsächlich dafür das ausfallen
zu lassen ja weil ich einfach gedacht
habe dass diese Tatsache dass wieder
Krieg ist ja dass das etwas so
ungeheuerliches ist und so weiter und
das ist eine gewisse Verhaltensänderung
auch irgendwie hervorbringen muss das
wie sichtbar sein sei es durch Bettlaken
oder dich ausgefallenen kann aber
und jetzt haben wir eine Weltlage die
viel viel schlimmer und viel
katastrophaler ist als damals dieser
zweite Golfkrieg und wir lassen eine
Fußball-Weltmeisterschaft stattfinden
sozusagen gedacht als Freudenfest
das ist nicht einfach ja also die Frage
ist wird es einem gelingen den den
Schalter umzulegen und zu sagen alle
Umstände sind mir egal Hauptsache ich
bringe mein Gehirn in Sicherheit oder
sich zu sagen unter diesen Umständen
kann ich da einfach nicht mit fiebern
wie bei einer normalen WM wie geht ihr
das
ich meine es ist eine ganz alte
moralische Frage die zu einem guten
gerade aufwirfst also darf man sich
trotzdem freuen uneingeschränkt freuen
wenn vor unserer Haustür in dem Fall
Menschen sterben das ist der Punkt und
die Frage wie würdest du das als ich
Spieß mal zurück den Ball in dem Fall
philosophisch beantworten ich würde ich
würde das darf daraus nehmen also ich
würde da keine Frage daraus machen ob
man das darf oder nicht darf aber du
weißt es eine Frage die viele Leute
beschäftigt aber das ist etwas was jeder
mit seinen eigenen moralischen Gefühlen
ausmachen muss es gibt da sozusagen kein
Obersten Gerichtshof der jetzt ein
Urteil fällt ob man das darf oder nicht
über den inneren Obersten Gerichtshof
genau aber genau aber muss anerkennen
dass der bei jedem ein anderes Urteil
spricht okay sozusagen kein Urteil was
man vorschreiben aber das ist aber das
ist doch schon mal ein wichtiger
Erkenntnis zu sagen das darf mir nicht
von außen irgendjemand richtig genau
vorschreiben also ich finde es völlig
falsch sich hinzustellen zu moralisieren
sozusagen du darfst diese WM in Seelen
Ruhe gucken alles in Ordnung und mach
dir mal keine Sorgen und genauso falsch
wäre es hinzugehen und sich mal sagen du
darfst keine werden gucken ich meine du
weißt das ja ich rege mich sowieso
darüber auf dass wir in einem Land leben
das zur gesinnungs ethischen
Überanstrengung neigt ja das also alles
moralisiert jeden Sprachgebrauch jede
Verhaltensweise jede politische Ansicht
und da werde ich nicht mitmachen ja und
ich werde dich nicht irgendjemanden
vorschreiben ob er die WM zu gucken hat
oder nicht sondern ich denke das muss
jeder seinen Gefühlen ausmachen wir
haben dieser Tage gerade im Fernsehen
noch darüber geredet Marcel Reif der
sagt es macht mich zu keinem
schlechteren Menschen wenn ich das gucke
ja sicher auch so Andreas Rettich der
Fußballmanager funktioniert der sagt
muss man boykottieren dann aber sehr
interessanter Moment einschränkt und
sagt okay also die deutschen Spiele
werde ich trotzdem schauen die sind
moralisch genau und
das Ding ist natürlich gab eine
herrliche Situation ist bezüglich in der
Sendung und ehrlich gesagt mochte ich
das aber weißt du warum also eigentlich
sah dabei nicht gut aus wir haben für
den vorwerfen moralisch völlig
inkonsistent zu sein und ich mochte aber
genau das genau dieses dieses Momentum
weil es zeigt wie wir Menschen halt sind
und dieses ne also auf der anderen Seite
das ist ja etwas ganz grundsätzliches
wir wir haben immer diese furchtbar
großen Ansprüche und nehmen auch für uns
sozusagen
an dass jeder ganz individuell
wahnsinnig moralisch ist
verurteilen alle anderen aber bei uns
selber sind wir deutlich deutlich
gnädiger absolut und in Wahrheit sind
wir einfach wahnsinnig autonistische
Wesen das ist mir da wieder klar
geworden und das hatte sowas
ungewollt entwaffnet ehrliches in dem
Moment ja ich glaube was er da erlebt
hat ist das was die Sozialpsychologen
eine kognitive Dissonanz ein ja das
heißt also Selbstbild und Fremdbild
stimmten für einige Sekunden es war
nicht mehr zusammen fünf am Ende der
Sendung wurde fünf Sekunden wo
Selbstbild und Weltbild
genau ja gut das ist ein menschlicher
Moment ja genau aber interessant aber
ich würde sagen ja ich finde man sollte
diese Frage nicht nur jetzt so aus der
Perspektive individual ethischer
Verantwortung Ja beantworten und jedem
jetzt sagen du musst jetzt sich jetzt in
große schwere moralische Entscheidung
treffen guckst oder guckst was aber echt
das ist finde ich total gut und wichtig
dass man festzuhalten ja ich finde ich
sehe was anderes ich mich interessiert
erst eigentlich eher im großen also wenn
man sich fragt wozu sind
Fußballweltmeisterschaften da ja was ist
eigentlich der Sinn von
Fußballweltmeisterschaften du weißt ja
ich vertrete die These dass das Gute am
Sport ist dass es für sehr sehr lange
Zeit den Krieg gelöst hat was ist eine
alterphilosophischer Gedanke von einem
Philosophen namens George santajana den
ich sehr schätze den heute keiner
bekennt und der hat das vor 100 Jahren
schon festgestellt und der hat damals
schon vermutet dass der Sport
insbesondere der Fußball ja eben im
zumindestens in Mittel- und Westeuropa
an die Stelle von Kriegen irgendwann
treten könnte dass wir also speziell der
Fußball ja ja das damals schon gesehen
ganz ganz früh witzig was also ich
beeindruckend ist total und ich glaube
tatsächlich dass er diese Funktion
gehabt hat dass man also Wettbewerb
Konkurrenz
zum Teil auch gibt mitunter Aggressionen
und so weiter so kanalisiert und in eine
spielerische Form bringt na ich meine
der Fußball ist ja durchdringt von
martialischen Begriffen denkt man den
Bomber der Nation ihre ja ein Begriff
den heute keiner mehr verwenden durfte
oder wie wurde der Mitreisende Fan
genannt Schlachten Bummler
übrigens eines der schönsten Worte der
deutschen Sprache ist der
Schlachtenbummler ja also großartig aber
da ist natürlich diese ganze Kriegs was
heißt das eigentlich genau ja das ist
der der immer zu den Griechenland zu den
Kriegsschauplätzen pilgert der
Schlachtenbummler ja so und es hat diese
Rolle übernommen das ist ja eine
wahnsinnig heilsame Rolle auch bei
Kopfbälle die Lufthoheit unserer Luft
martialisch alles sehr sehr martialisch
aber eigentlich alles in einer netten
Sache ist der Fußball hat sich auch
verändert er ist immer auf dem Platz
immer friedlicher geworden genau ne also
Fouls gehörten früher selbstverständlich
dazu wer sich darüber aufregt der meine
Memme ja wenn heute einer gefoult wird
dann schlägt er die Hände vors Gesicht
und rollt sechs Mal über den Boden wie
diejenigen die früher in diesen Serien
Western von gestern erschossen wurde
wenn da einer erschossen wurde entfiel
der theatralisch um ja und und welche
sich noch fünf Mal vor sich hin und
diese Western von gestern ja Mimik ja
die hatten heute Einzug gehalten und da
traut sich auch keiner mehr richtig zu
faul genau Western begeistern ich
erinnere mich ich habe das früher immer
geguckt Western von gestern war als Kind
weiß ich noch irritiert manchmal fiel ja
schon bevor der Schuss gefallen ist das
stimmt hatte ich immer dann Verdacht
irgendwas stimmt hier vielleicht nicht
also das Umfallen war es kam aufs
Umfallen drauf an und das weiter bei
Western von gestern war dass die Pferde
außerhalb als wären die 200
Stundenkilometer schnell weil die so
wenig Bilder pro Sekunde hatten waren
die Pferde unfassbar schnell so dass
mein kleiner Bruder mich gefragt hat ob
Pferde früher schneller laufen konnte
als großartig ja aber das das wiederum
erinnert mich an Baywatch ja ich hatte
mal ein sehr lustiges Gespräch mit David
Hasselhoff und der Gegend ausgelassen in
deinem Leben gar nichts keine
Berührungsängste kannst du dir noch
angucken die eine der legendärsten
Sendungen die wir je gemacht haben
Christian Lindner trifft auf Luisa
Neubauer David Hasselhoff und Bettina
Tietjen tolle Kombi legendär Bettchen
die ein Buch mitgebracht hatte über
Campingurlaub ein sehr lustiges Buch
über Campingurlaub Christian Lindner der
groß über Politik erzählte und David
Hasselhoff und Luisa Neubauer so ein
bisschen die Welt erklärte und David
Hasselhoff der vor der Sendung zu
weniger darüber kam war gerade wieder
frisch verliebt hatte und eine sehr
nette Verkäuferin aus England irgendwo
im Supermarkt getroffen und das war ab
der Sekunde dann seine neue
Lebensgefährtin und und sagte zu mir
Markus meine neue Freundin hat zu mir
gesagt misch dich nicht in die Politik
ein und ich werde mich daran halten frag
mich bitte auch nichts wir reden nicht
über Politik und dann fing Christian
Lindner an zu erzählen und zu erzählen
und kam so leicht den schwadronieren
muss man so sagen und irgendwann konnte
der Knight Rider nicht mehr anders und
hat ihn einfach komplett überfahren es
war unvorstellbar plötzlich brach es aus
ihm heraus und der ging hin so frontal
an und hinterher hat er sich dann bei
mir noch mal dafür entschuldigt und sagt
ja ich wollte doch nicht die Politik und
sowas tut mir leid
genau aber die Geschichte ist du weißt
warum es immer diese diese mega
Zeitlupen gab David Hasselhoff in
Baywatch oder auch Pamela Anderson
laufen in Zeiten über den Strand über
den Strand weißt du warum
zu sehen
nee also welche Körperteile wippen
welche halten und so weiter
Sixpack oder nicht und wackelt der und
so weiter der Begriff Boje der noch mal
ein ganz anderer Bedeutung kriegt ja nee
sondern er sagte mir was die Wahrheit
ist wir hatten immer zu wenig Handlung
und wir mussten die Zeit dann strecken
wir mussten auf die 45 Minuten kommen
oder eine Stunde ich weiß nicht mehr und
das haben wir dann überbrückt indem es
einfach in Zeitlupe am laufen lassen
damit haben die sehr viel Geld verdient
man mussten weniger drehen ja und dann
wurde das aber so eine ganz eigene
Ästhetik also der Gegenentwurf zu
Western von gestern zu deinem
superschnellen
also Sport ja zurück also Funktion von
Fußballweltmeisterschaft also vielleicht
ist das für mich vielleicht bin ich doch
kitschig und voreingenommen 2006 war so
mein ganz ganz großes Highlight werden
im eigenen Land hast du geguckt ich habe
jedes Studium im Stadion leider leider
nicht ich war in Köln ja damals siehst
da waren wir ganz nah einander ich habe
ja in Köln gewohnt ja Ukraine ja ich
auch ja du hast Ukraine gegen Schweiz
gesehen genau das war das Spiel was in
Köln statt
wirklich schlechteste Spiel das seit bei
einer WM gespielt wurde mit Ausnahme des
legendären nichtangriffspakts von Giron
das war das Spiel wo Österreich und
Deutschland sich nicht wehtun das
Schämen die sich heute noch fehlen zu
Recht ja also das ist sozusagen ein meme
ja das nie wieder vergehen wird und aber
mein Spiel ohne Torchance gegen es war
ein Gehacke und geheult und das ein
ungerottenschlechtes Elfmeterschießen
ich habe vergessen aber ich muss dazu
eins sagen zu diesem Spiel ja ich war ja
glühender Fan der Ukraine du weißt ja
dass meine Fußball Sozialisation
Ukrainisch ist nee ich meine ich hätte
das schon mal erzählt also ich kann mir
aus einem linken Elternhaus ja meine
Eltern waren gegen Fußball da gab es ja
nur eine Möglichkeit oder einen Trick ja
ich nehme mir eine linke Mannschaft und
zu dem damaligen Zeitpunkt war das
dynamokiert
70er Jahren diese legendäre Mannschaft
genau richtig genau alle ja
so spricht man sie Bitte ausgesprochen
na ja und jedenfalls also dadurch bin
ich
jemand andere Leute Schalke-Fans wir
haben ja weil weil der Opa für Schalke
ist wo wollen wir als Kind schon dafür
war ist das wenn ich Dynamo Kia Fan das
finde ich auch immer geblieben ja das
war dann in das war dann nachher ab der
90er Jahren schwierig weil dann das
waren Oligarchen Klo genau ja der Eine
Goethe achmedopf eine andere gute surkis
und soweit ich habe mich mit Uli Hoeneß
mal sehr über Oligarchen und
ukrainischen Fußball und interessant ja
und jedenfalls wie dem auch sei ich war
leidenschaftlich für die Ukraine aus
diesem Gründen ja und erstmal was durch
die fürchterlich diese Spiel anzusehen
in denen nichts funktioniert auf beiden
Seiten überhaupt nichts ging und dann
kann man das Elfmeterschießen wirklich
mit feuchten hinten
und ich hatte nur so eine blöde kleine
Zimmerantenne ich war ja damals
irgendwie nicht so betucht in der WG
nicht rein als 2006 habe ich nicht in
der WG gewohnt weil ich gerade umgezogen
und in Köln Engelbertstraße und und
direkt gegenüber guckt auch jemand und
zwar ein Schweizer und dessen
Kabelverbindung war locker zwei Sekunden
schneller als meine Zimmerantenne das
heißt also wenn der Spieler an die hörte
ich schon aus dem Fenster gegenüber wird
ausgeht und der war nur am lamentieren
und tatsächlich haben die Schweizer alle
Elfer verschossen ja und die Ukraine
brauchten glaube ich nur zwei Treffer
und damit durchzukommen dieses
großartige Spiel hast du gesehen habe
ich gesehen ehrlich gesagt mein
großartiges Spiel war Deutschland
Italien in Dortmund ja das habe ich für
wen warst du da ich saß da sehr neutral
drin habe mich nicht als Italiener zu
erkennen gegeben ich habe ja ein
italienischen Pass weil ich mitten
mittendrin ganz hinten oben Tribüne
mittendrin im Hardcore deutschen
Fanblock saß und es gab eine großartige
Szene so so schräg unter mir
saßen noch
Italiener
das waren Jungs aus so einer Pizzeria in
Essen bis ich dann später rausstellte
und die saßen da mittendrin und es wurde
gesungen die ganze Zeit ihr seid ja nur
Pizza Lieferant Pizza Lieferant
mit anderen Mitteln ja und und die Laune
dieser beiden italienischen Pizzabäcker
wurde schlechter und schlechter und
schlechter ich saß damit meinem sehr
guten Freund Frank Birner dem ich damals
liebe Grüße zusammen gearbeitet habe
sehr nett war das und Frank auch so ein
hardcore-fußballfan und wir saßen da
drin und es ging so hin und her und so
weiter und dann kam dieses eine Ding ja
was war das 118 119 minute als Italiener
das Spiel ihre Verlängerung für sich
entschieden haben Andrea Toten Stille
genau Toten still in diesen vor mir
weinten Menschen die konnten es nicht
fassen was da passiert ist und in viele
Deutsche Stille rein springt dieser
Pizzabäcker aus aus Essen Recklinghausen
war immer her war springt auf dreht sich
um und schreit guck mal so backt man
Pizza
das war unvorstellbar
und ich fand es aber auch schön
interessant ich da okay ich dachte der
fängt sich jetzt ein ja hat aber keiner
gemacht aber da dachte ich guck mal das
ist eben Sport das ist Sport dann am
Ende auch fairer Verlierer ja es war es
war 2006 alles wirkte so als wäre es
sicher dass Deutschland Weltmeister
2006 den bis dato besten Fußball
gespielt den es je bei einer WM gespielt
hat und dieses Zauber Duo Poldi und
Schweini und so weiter da wurden
Schweden wurden zu flugscharen wirklich
ich wollte das Spiel sehen ja gegenüber
in der Kneipe und bin hochgegangen und
habe aus meiner Wohnung weil keine
Stühle mehr da waren wir einfach zwei
Stühle selber genommen und ich bin
hochgeamt die Schüler geholt kam runter
stand 2:0 für Deutschland ja hier kein
Tor mehr also ich habe genau die
entscheidenden ersten 10 verfassen
dadurch verpasst nein aber das Schöne
bei so einer WM ist man hat mit jedem
Menschen sofort ein Gesprächsthema es
gibt in Köln leicht ja wenn du in Köln
an der Theke sitzt und Kölsch trinkst
dann hast du auch mit jedem
menschenstellen Gesprächsthema aber
niemals so flächenübergreifend ja vom
Kiosk bis zur Tankstelle und so weiter
also alles das was sonst Menschen
voneinander trennt spielt dann
eigentlich keine Rolle mehr man dreht
gemeinsam gefühlt den gleichen Film egal
ob man für die eine oder andere
Mannschaft ist und das ist glaube ich
ein unglaublich verbindender Wert von
Fußballweltmeisterschaften und da stelle
ich mir natürlich so ein bisschen die
Frage und das ist gar keine moralische
Frage keine individualmoralische Frage
die Frage wie wird das denn jetzt in
diesem Winter sein
ja hast du recht ich
habe in dieser Sendung auch was
Sebastian Sohns ist ein totaler
Fußballfan der wollte mal Fußball
Kommentator auch werden Sportjournalist
werden ist dann aber
Islamwissenschaftler geworden sehr ganz
interessante Geschichte toller Typen
toller Erzähler sehr druckvoll deren
wirklich gutes Buch geschrieben hat über
dieses Thema hat sich lange in der
Golfregion speziell auch in Katar und so
weiter aufgehalten und kennt diese
ganzen Geschichten und was ich
interessant fand war und es war so ein
kleiner Moment auch der Erlösung die
Lektüre dieses Buches
Sebastian Sohns schafft es eben auf
diese Grautöne auch wirklich einzugehen
hat damit ein paar Dingen mal aufgeräumt
und zum Beispiel mit der mit diesen
Zahlen die da mal kursieren über die
über die unglaublich vielen Toten die
offensichtlich Zurückgehen auf einen
berichtigen Guardian vor Jahren schon
und die aber alle so nicht wirklich zu
verifizieren sind also offenkundig
scheint es sozusagen dass auf der
Baustellen die es speziell Stadien und
so weiter sind sehr sehr viele
Fortschritte gemacht worden sind das
bestätigt übrigens sagt er auch sogar
amnesty international sehr interessant
Amnesty sagt nee Boykott das ist nicht
etwas was wir in unserem Werkzeugkasten
haben und es gibt auch da Verbesserungen
das müsst ihr bitte auch mal zur
Kenntnis nehmen speziell auch in Katar
das heißt dieses sportwashing an dem
Punkt funktioniert so nicht die sind da
nämlich durchaus unter Druck geraten
dadurch dass plötzlich die Augen der
ganzen Welt auf sie gerichtet waren und
man musste dort Dinge verbessern die
offiziellen Zahlen der FIFA Infantino
läuft durch die Gegend und sagt da gab
es drei Tote aber das ist ja auch
furchtbar so dann genau dann dann sagt
man nahe da gibt es auch noch 37 andere
nicht wirklich verifizierte Todesfälle
und daraus resultiert natürlich eine
andere harte moralische Frage ab wie
vielen Toten gucken wir denn dann keine
WM mehr ganz zynische ekelhafte Frage
also es scheint so zu sein dass viele
dieser Toten dieser armen Leute ungefähr
zwei Regionen Arbeiter die aus Nepal
Bangladesch vor allen Dingen kommen um
dort in der Golfregion Geld zu verdienen
dass viele von denen auch auf anderen
Baustellen gestorben sind Straßenbau
Hotelbau und so weiter und das wiederum
führt natürlich direkt zur übernächsten
Frage also ist es sozusagen okay wenn
dann deutsche Touristen im Winter nach
Dubai ähnliche Zustände durchaus als als
Dubai im ganz großen Stil erbaut wurde
so das moderne Duba wie wir es heute
kennen oder jetzt auch eben nach nach
Doha oder woanders hinfliegen um dort im
Winter sich sozusagen die Sonne auf den
Pelz scheinen zu lassen dann ignorieren
wir die ganzen Toten Nepalesen aber bei
der Fußball-WM ist es plötzlich ein
Riesenthema das ist natürlich die
Scheinheiligkeit auf die Sebastian Sohns
da hinweist und hat er absolut ein Punkt
finde ich ja also in der ähnliche
Argumentation habe ich vor kurzem gehört
ich war in Lüneburg einmal machen wir
jedes Jahr die utopie-konferenz und da
war jemand von der FIFA der da sehr
lange gearbeitet hatte und er sagte er
wäre ja so ein Aussteiger ja ein
Aussteiger kann man so sagen hat sich
mit Infantino nicht verstanden ja der
jetzt in Doha ein Haus hat weißt du das
der wohnt da ja schon und und Andreas
Rettich meinte ich denke ich warte
darauf bis er nach Riad umzieht okay
genau
haben sich wechselseitig verdient
wirklich war also und der hat mir auch
gesagt er muss ja eins sehen also seit
das Auge der Weltöffentlichkeit
darauf fällt genau wie da die Arbeiter
behandelt werden und wer auf dem
Baustellen stirbt und unter welchen
Bedingungen die ihn arbeiten hat sich
natürlich massiv etwas verbessert so
weil nirgendwo gibt es Baustellen die so
sehr unter internationaler Beobachtung
stehen wie die für die WM Stadien er
sagte mir auch gleichzeitig und dasselbe
was du auch gesagt hast auf einen
anderen Baustellen die mit der WM nichts
zu tun haben sind die Zustände immer
noch grottig exakt so aber gerade da hat
man aber in den WM Baustellen haben sich
die Verhältnisse deutlich verbessert und
die alles entscheidende Frage ist ja wie
wird das nach der WM sein wenn ja glaube
ich die Stadion zum Teil wieder abgebaut
und die Frage ist und die Frage ist
unter welchen Umständen also wird
nachdem so viel Licht auf Katar gefallen
ist sich dauerhaft irgendwo etwas
verbessern oder wird wenn das Licht weg
ist ja der Schatten sich wieder
ausbreiten und das eine Frage die kann
keiner genau beantworten kann man sagen
was einheitlich für wahrscheinlich aber
das weiß man nicht genau das wird
natürlich am Ende letztlich die
entscheidende Frage sein und die können
wir nicht beantworten aber dieses
Argument das sind die wm-baustellen doch
jetzt erstmal einen Fortschritt gebracht
haben das ist in der Welt ja und ich
meine Uli Hoeneß ist auch jemand der das
immer wieder lautstark ja Uli Hoeneß
hatte ja alles eine wie soll man sagen
mit mit gerade mit Andreas Rettig eine
eine fern mündliche Kollision ja sicher
hat sich ja beim Doppelpass da
zugeschaltet sich selber zugeschaltet
und hat los gepoltert und Andreas rette
ich den König der scheinheiligen genannt
weil er genau diese Zustände moniert ich
meine ist schon Argument ne niemand
niemand hätte sich für die Toten auf
Baustelle in Katar jemals interessiert
wenn dort nicht diese stimmen würde
ob es trotzdem eine gute Idee ist die
werden da stattfinden zu lassen gibt es
ja noch viele andere Argumente es ging
ja nicht allein um die Toten auf dem
Baustellen es geht ja auch darum dass
wir in den Worten unserer
Außenministerin jetzt eine Werte
geleitete Außenpolitik machen und
Fußball ist immer ein Teil von
Außenpolitik was auch unter da habe ich
jetzt
glaube ich ein spannende Gedanken für
dich Richard wenn es so ist wie du sagst
und du hast ja gerade auch so dieses
Völker verbindende und dieses ja dieses
dieses Momentum so schön beschrieben in
dem wirklich sich Menschen aus allen
Schichten aus allen Nationen aus der
ganzen Welt zusammenfinden um die um den
gleichen Film mit so genau und das hat
ja was wahnsinnig Volker verbindendes
also ich sag mal 2006 für mich ist 2006
das Lebensgefühl dieses Sommers 2006 du
weißt ich bin in der Mitte der 90er nach
Deutschland gekommen und da war so
dieses war so dieses bleierne Helmut
kohl-gefühl ja
2006 ist Deutschland lässig geworden und
es ist lässig geblieben ja also
2006 bei dieser
Fußball-Weltmeisterschaft ist aus
Patriotismus Party
utismus ja und der Grund warum das
passiert ist also diese oft sehr
aggressive Stimmung die beim Fußball
gucken Aufgaben haben solange die Männer
weitgehend unter sich waren 2006 war für
mich die WM der Frauen so es waren beim
Fußball gucken genauso viele mit
Fähnchen angemalte Frauen dabei wie
Männer genau und dadurch entstand eher
so eine partygefühl beim Fußball gucken
abgesehen davon dass Deutschland auch
tollen partyfußball gespielt hat und ich
mir diesen Rumpel und kampffußball also
alles das fasste zusammen und das zeigte
so ein so ein gelöstes genauso ein
unaggressives so ein offenes so ein
modernes Deutschland
genau das war das Ding so und jetzt der
der Gedanke
wenn wenn das so ist wenn also Fußball
eine Kraft hat und wenn das was bewegt
jetzt stell dir mal für eine Sekunde vor
wird das jetzt nicht nach Katar vergeben
sondern wir würden sagen pass auf wir
nehmen jetzt gleich noch die anderen
auch noch mit die anderen Probleme Bären
Katha Saudi-Arabien Iran ja dort tragen
wir die Fußballweltmeisterschaft aus ja
also im Iran im Iran also dass ich sehe
es ganz unterschiedlich gibt die
wahnsinnige Fußballbegeisterung
ja aber auch im Iran also Iran ist ein
riesenfußball so genau im Iran wäre es
für das molaregime gefährlich so das
meine ich aber für die Herrschaft
Herrscherfamilie von Saudi Arabien in
Salman ja wer es nicht gefährlich ist
glaube ich auch nicht da sehe ich einen
großen Unterschied also der Iran ist ja
ein grandioses großartiges Land über das
wir im Augenblick viel zu wenig sprechen
und wir reden häufiger darüber
tatsächlich
ja also beide ja ja aber das
der Iran das Potenzial hat dass da
tatsächlich eine eine Revolution
ausbricht quasi in Folge einer einer
weltöffnung das halte ich tatsächlich
sogar für denkbar aber ich halte das in
Katar und den Saudi Arabien nicht für
vorstellen
ja es gibt es gibt es ist interessant ne
wenn man sich mal anschaut und da kommt
wieder so ein Punkt und deswegen ist man
da immer so ambivalent und immer so hin
und her gerissen
es gibt diese es gibt 300.000 Kataris
ich habe als ich als ich das jetzt hörte
dachte ich na gut dann kann sie
eigentlich aus Südtirol jetzt mal für
eine Fußball-WM bewerben ne ja also ich
meine ja wir sind schönes Land
sympathische Leute gute Sachen ein
Stadion in Bozen kriegen wir auch noch
hin eine eigene Nation seid ihr auch
gefühlt auf jeden Fall wir sind auf
jeden Fall Südtiroler eigentlich
geburtsitaliener und gemütt Deutsch
diese Begrifflichkeiten würde ich
komplett weglassen ihr seid Südtiroler
wir sind Südtiroler erstmal
ja nein nein auch das nicht es ist jetzt
nicht so ein primitiver Patriotismus
irgendwie also damit sage ich nicht dass
die Bayern da primitiv patriotisch sind
überhaupt nicht aber interessanterweise
gibt es ein tiefes gegenseitiges
Verständnis also die Südtiroler mögen
sehr die Bayern und die Bayern mögen
sehr die Südtiroler und ich glaube das
kommt genau aus Gefühl heraus die
gallische Dörfer
[Musik]
von dem sie sich gefühlt unabhängig
fühlen ja mit Hand zu einem gewissen
Größen Bahn also wir wir machen uns wir
sind so der der Dackel der sich immer
gegen den Dobermann aufregt oder
aufregend ja also
versteht wie kleine eigentlich
gefühlt alle Zaubertrank getrunken ja
und so kommt ein Reinhold Messner
Zustande genau und Luis
ja genau nein aber was ich was ich meine
ist das ist ja eigentlich eine sehr
schöne Art von von Patriotismus insofern
als sie dies sehr begrenzt auf eine
Region wie wir wir wollen auch gar nicht
großartig irgendwie die Dinge verändern
was Nationen angeht dieses Konstrukt der
Nation von dem wir auch schon ein paar
mal gesagt haben das hat sich
wahrscheinlich so wie es jetzt auch ist
in einer Art und Weise in einer Welt die
immer enger zusammenwächst auch überholt
ja Teil überholt teilweise teilweise
genau es gibt ja das macht die Sache so
schwierig macht die Sache so schwierig
auch da wieder genau aber diese Idee
dass Europa der Regionen sozusagen ja
das sind wir und deswegen da Leben ich
meine da Leben drei sprachgrupp zusammen
das ist ein bisschen wirklich was das
angeht wie ein Katar also schwierig es
gibt nicht die katarische Gesellschaft
darauf weist auch Sebastian sohnssinn
sondern sagt da gibt es 300.000 Kataris
dann gibt es eine nennenswerte Zahl von
von europäischen Ausländern im Sinne von
Ingenieure Manager Leute sagt ja auch in
Saudi-Arabien die verdienen gerade so
viel Kohle mit Öl und Gas und Kata
natürlich auch dass die nicht wissen
wohin mit der Kohle da ist eine
gigantische Aufbruchstimmung und jeder
mittelklassige Manager kriegt sofort
eine Million Dollar einfach dafür dass
er kommt und beim Aufbau sozusagen
dieses Landes hilft dass der die geben
da jetzt richtig Gas und dann gibt es
diese ungefähr zwei Millionen in Katar
Gastarbeiter und da gibt es natürlich
ein problematisches System da gibt es
dieses Kavala System kennst du das das
ist sozusagen ein ursprünglich
eigentlich ein eine schöne Idee die aus
dieser beduinischen Gastfreundschaft
also ja ursprünglich so hat was mit
Gastfreundschaft zu tun mittlerweile
komplett pervertiert so quasi ein ein
Staatsbürger von Katar von denen
Sebastian Sohn sagt die Leute müssen
eigentlich nicht arbeiten diese 300.000
gehören zu einer kleinen schmalen Elite
genau die Arbeiten sozusagen um sich
selbst zu verwirklichen aber genau man
muss es nicht wirklich
und und dann gibt es eben dieses Heer
von diesen zwei Millionen und auch da
wieder diese diese Ambivalenz also du
bürgst als kathari für einen armen
Nepalesen oder jemanden aus Bangladesch
zum Beispiel die Familien in Bangladesch
Nepal legen teilweise unglaublich viel
Geld dafür hin um überhaupt die Chance
zu kriegen von von in Katar arbeiten zu
dürfen dass jemand für dich ja diese sie
Bürgschaft quasi übernimmt und daraus
ist auch ein hochkommen
korruptes Geschäftsmodell geworden das
heißt du wirkst nicht nur für einen
sondern für mehrere und dann
verschacherst du diese Bürgschaft wieder
an den nächsten und so weiter die im
Grund ist das Sklavenhandel das ist
nichts anderes und dann arbeiten die
Leute für im Schnitt ungefähr 250 270
280 Dollar im Monat das könnte man sagen
relativ nein ist es eben nicht Richard
Obacht das dachte ich auch dachte gut
vielleicht Lebenshaltungskosten
günstiger in Afrika irgendwo sind 270
Dollar im Zweifel viel Geld mitnichten
das Leben in in Katar ist ungefähr so
teuer und teilweise teurer als das Leben
wie in Deutschland das heißt du bist die
Familienname Sau aber die Familien haben
die dahin geschickt
weil sie in Nepal 30 Dollar im Monat
richtig aber die Hoffnung dass die von
dem wenigen Geld was in Katha kriegen
noch was abzweigen was auch passiert
natürlich unter erbärmlichen Umständen
nach Hause Quartieren und so weiter also
gar kein richtiges Leben haben das ist
der Punkt so das ist das ist ein
erbärmliches Leben das muss man wirklich
so deutlich sagen und dazu kommt
natürlich schwierige Finanzierungen
Wechselkurs angedeutet da gibt es
Verbindungen in den Irak nach Syrien al
nusra al-Qaida die Taliban und so weiter
Bremen Krieg und auch da wieder diese
Ambivalenz ich erinnere mich als
Deutschland das als Afghanistan war die
Amerikaner über Nacht daraus kopflos
dann diese furchtbaren Szenen am
Flughafen in Kabul und die Frage für die
deutsche Politik wie kriegen wir unsere
Leute da jetzt raus pragmatisch mit
Hilfe der Katharina genauso ist es
gelaufen und das sagt dir keiner
öffentlich im Fernsehen sondern
hintenrum wenn du dann fragst sagt wie
wie habt ihr das denn gemacht wer sind
denn eure Gesprächskanäle wer hilft euch
denn dabei dann sagen die Leute die
öffentlich ich will jetzt keine Namen
nennen aber öffentlich im Fernsehen
verurteilen die Menschenrechtssituation
in Katar die die sehr moralisch
argumentieren und sagen
Fußballweltmeisterschaft dort du kannst
dir vorstellen aus welcher Ecke das
kommt dieselben Leute sagen die durch
traust mich gar nicht laut zu sagen aber
ich rufe uns dabei das ist unser
einziger Kanal zu den Taliban also
Doppelmoral genau ist die natürlichste
Sache der Politik so selbst jetzt wo wir
diese Russland Sanktionen so sehr
verschärft haben genau freuen wir uns
immer noch über das Gas ja das nach wie
vor aus Russland kommt so dass die hast
du ja die gleiche doppelmoralspiel also
wir haben einen unglaublichen Aufwand an
Moral aber wenn es um eingemachte
Interessen geht dann finden wir noch
immer irgendwelche Wege ja wie wir diese
moralische große Verantwortung von der
wir sprechen selbst für uns umgehen
können
aber ich würde jetzt gerne von dir
wissen nachdem du das jetzt so
ausführlich dargestellt hast also die
Arbeitssituation in Katar ja auch die
politischen deine kleine persönliche
Entscheidung wie du jetzt diese WM
bewertest und ob du sie gucken wirst
also ich werde sie gucken definitiv weil
ich ich bin kein großer Fußballgucker
was jetzt Bundesliga ist und so weiter
ich werde es auch ohne schlechtes
Gewissen gucken aber natürlich muss man
diese
ich glaube man muss sich viele Dinge
bewusst werden und mich hat mich hat es
eben schon gesagt dieses dieses
dilektüre des Buches von Sebastian Sohns
da sehr ins Grübeln gebracht und hat mir
halt eben wieder gezeigt wie
scheinheilig wie an vielen Stellen sind
also ich sag mal so
man könnte ja auch sagen wo ist der
große boykrotte Aufruf wenn
grundsätzlich
Fußballweltmeisterschaften gespielt
werden und wir wissen unter welchen
Bedingungen Sport Fußballschuhe in
Bangladesch und woanders für uns
zusammengeschraubt werden
du kannst auf der anderen Seite ja nicht
erwarten dass jeder Mensch ein Heiliger
wird so heißt also aus gewissen
moralischen doppelmoralischen
Verstrickungen kommt überhaupt keiner
raus völlig mit sich im Rhein sind immer
nur die dummen ja und jeder Mensch der
Teilnehmer Zustand ne ja der ist
unschuldig aber jeder der halbwegs über
sich selber nachdenkt natürlich dass er
in moralischen
verstrickungszusammenhängen ist indem
sie nicht gelingen wird ein Heiliger zu
werden genau also muss ja der Anspruch
den man an sich selbst stellt nicht
derjenige sein ein Heiliger sein zu
wollen sondern im Rahmen
bestimmte Verstrickungen sich nicht
vermeiden lassen ja das so zu machen
dass man denkt das was ich tue und was
was ich sage das ist halbwegs so genau
das ist eine Frage habe ich mir nicht
überlegt das kommt hängt so ein bisschen
drauf an ich gucke dass er sehr gerne
mit meinem Sohn zusammen oder mit meiner
Lebensgefährtin aber meine
Lebensgefährtin ist ja glühende Spanien
Fan und ihr Lieblingsverein ist
Athletico Madrid
und also sie wird sie nicht davon
abbringen lassen Spanien zu gucken also
ich glaube ich werde das situativ
irgendwie abhängig machen wie sich das
entwickelt aber ich ich glaube schon
vor vier Jahren die oder wie lang ist es
jetzt hier noch länger Weltmeisterschaft
in Russland ja da war das zum ersten Mal
so dass das allgemeine Fußball Interesse
abgenommen hat ja das heißt da war der
Peak überschritten und ich vermute schon
Peak Oil pik-fußball pig Fussball dass
dieser pik-fußball dass das noch weiter
runter gehen das glaube ich schon so und
dann muss ich die FIFA wirklich noch mal
neu überlegen ja ob man und der Grund
wird er hat ja nichts mit
Menschenrechtsverletzungen Katar zu ne
der Grund hat da was damit zu tun dass
Katar kein Fußball Land ist und dass das
Ganze im Winter stattfindet und dass das
in einer Zeit stattfindet wo die Leute
wirklich eine Menge anderer Sorgen haben
also es gibt viele Umstände die jetzt
gegen Katar sprechen
und da ist die arbeitsrechtliche
Situation und die Situation auf den
Baustellen und wirklich gar nicht das
Hauptthema also wenn du wenn du sagst
Fußball ganz grundsätzlich ne also ich
ich habe das noch mal nachgelesen im
Grunde ist es so seit 1998 nachweislich
ist keine einzige WM mehr ohne
Korruption vergeben worden ja nicht eine
einzige 98 bedeutet auch das
Sommermärchen ja das bekanntermaßen wo
ich ja immer du kennst ja meine Meinung
dazu ne ich finde ja der Beckenbauer
hätte hingehen sollen und sagen können
haben wir das nicht geil gemacht was
haben wir dafür bezahlt 8 Millionen oder
zwölf oder so es gibt also auch da führt
die Spur führt übrigens nach Katars
weißt du nicht ja es gibt diesen
steinreichen katarischen Bauunternehmer
der Mohammed Mohammed ganz genau den
Beckenbauer immer so großartig
ausgesprochen
der hat nachweislich 6,7 Millionen Euro
bekommen
für das deutsche Sommermärchen
6,7 Millionen dafür bauen sich andere
Leute eine riesen Veranda ich meine für
so wenig Geld der hätte stolz drauf sein
können ich bin sicher all die anderen ja
wir haben viel deutlich mehr bezahlt so
und dann hätte er sagen können ne also
so läuft
und sagen können ja ich meine wer nicht
schmiert kriegt auch keine WM zeig mir
mal eine nach 98 wo nicht geschmiert
worden wäre dann wäre zwar
strafrechtlich belangt worden dass dabei
für sein Image ja wäre das Gold gewesen
hätte man gesagt die alte Schwere nöter
der Beckenbauer und so weiter der hat
uns die auch noch besonders günstig
besorgt ja im Nachhinein ist das ja so
ich meine was für eine lächerliche
kleine Summe um eine Weltmeisterschaft
zu kaufen ja wenn das die ganze Wahrheit
ist dass das irre ist ich auch das noch
mal die Zahl ist wirklich fantastisch
von 43 Angeklagten funktionieren ne sind
28 dann tatsächlich verurteilt worden zu
was dazu Haftstrafen zu Geldstrafen
womöglich ja soweit ich weiß 8 6 8 keine
Ahnung also einige auf jeden Fall sind
wirklich im Bau gewandert und das finde
ich ganz bemerkenswert das interessant
ist halt dass man immer dachte daraus
erwächst jetzt was und hinterher ist der
Fußball oder die FIFA aufpassen weniger
korrupt
bin mir nicht sicher ob man das so
uneingeschränkt sagen kann sag ich mal
so stehen geht Korruption nicht weg weil
die meisten Leute haben ja nur einen
Wunsch entweder weniger Korruption oder
die Möglichkeit davon zu profitieren und
wählen die FIFA kommt hat die
Möglichkeit davon zu profitieren und das
ist wahrscheinlich ein nicht ganz
unstarkes Motiv überhaupt damit zu
mischen also ich glaube das wird nicht
auf das ist der der Blatter als er
damals diesen diesen Umschlag daraus
zieht und da steht Katar drauf der hatte
ja geguckt als hätte er gerade in so
einem Strauch Knoblauch reingemessen ja
weil das ja natürlich auch klar war
Katar ist ja für die FIFA ungünstig
und Qatar ist auch extrem ungünstig für
die gesamte Sportartikelindustrie die ja
ein ganz großer Rolle spielte ich kann
mir nicht vorstellen dass Adidas sich so
über Katar gefreut hat da entsteht ja
kein Markt ja also wenn sowas in China
stattfindet dann wäre das sehr sehr
reizvoll weil man sagen kann China ist
dann Entwicklungsland im Hinblick auf
Fußball ja und da kann man noch
gigantische Geschäfte machen
mittlerweile gibt es die große
chinesische Mittelschicht was kann man
da nicht alles an Fußballschuhen
verkaufen ja und an Fußball aber doch
nicht in Karta wo man danach erwartet
dass die Stadien irgendwie wenn sie
überhaupt bestehen bleiben nicht mehr
für Fußball genutzt werden vielleicht
nicht aber wenn Du Dir mal überlegst was
für eine junge Bevölkerung überhaupt der
gesamte Nahe Osten hat ne was für eine
Fußballbegeisterung ist sie das auch
immer in Israel zum Beispiel oder wenn
du Investoren Land unterwegs bist was da
für eine Fußballbegeisterung ist und
Fußball das einzige Ding ja was was
sozusagen noch mal ein bisschen
Ablenkung in dieser ganzen
Trostlosigkeit bietet da würde ich schon
sagen aber da wäre der fußballmarkt
Fußball WM in Ägypten oder so naheliegen
gewesen ja also Ägypten eine sehr gute
Fußballmannschaft genau wie Algerien
Marokko Tunesien ja alles alles richtige
Fußball Länder mit konkurrenzfähigen
Mannschaften und ich glaube das wäre
auch in die gesamte arabische Welt
abgestrahlt ja und ich meine ägypten ist
ein sehr bevölkerungsreiches Land und da
gibt es auch eine Fußball-Liga die ist
ja in dieser Form in Katar eigentlich
gar nicht gibt also das alles wäre ja
sehr sehr viel günstiger gewesen die
Frage ist mariiert also darum geht es ja
eigentlich haben wir sozusagen Grund zur
Hoffnung dass so ein großer Ereignis
wirklich vor Ort etwas verändert und da
gibt es Leute die sagen auf gar keinen
Fall ich bin mir da nicht so sicher ich
habe ein konkretes Beispiel für dich USA
wenn es sich 94
ich habe so eine Gruppe habe ich die
Zeit im Kopf als dort die
Fußball-Weltmeisterschaft angelaufen ist
war Fußball in der Liste der
beliebtesten Sportarten in den USA auf
welchem Platz
nicht unter den Top 20
so irgendwie 95 oder 96 also ich meine
auch Fußball jedenfalls genau aber
irgendwo Platz 94,95 wahrscheinlich
hinter Schach oder Halma oder keine
Ahnung was so heute ist Fußball eine der
beliebtesten Sportarten in den USA das
Platz vier oder fünf
es gibt aber noch ein anderes Potenzial
mit den Stadien was dann da ist also
tatsächlich den Kraft dass meine ich
jetzt das meine ich es hat eine Kraft
und die Frage ist was entwickelt sich
daraus ich fand damals schon doof dass
die Fußball-WM 94 in USA stattfand da
konnte ich mir noch gar nicht ausmalen
dass sie irgendwann mal Katar
stattfinden würde ja ich fand das damals
schon mit USA doof wobei ich sehr schöne
Erinnerungen an die Fußball 94 habe es
war aus meiner Sicht die skurrilste WM
ja also das war die WM mit mit
Effenberger Stinkefinger ja es war die
die WM wo sehr schräge Typen waren also
muss ich nur die kolumbianische
Nationalmannschaft vor Augen da gab
esita ja wie so aussah wie so ein
Drogenbaron der da im Tor war ja in dem
man sich heute in so einem Splatter Film
mit Machete vorstellen kann und es gab
Carlos Valderrama ja genau an den Pudel
Carlos also Rudi Völler hatte ja damals
auch in seiner Glanzzeit diese Matte
aber bei Rudi Völler waren die Haare
immer ein bisschen dünn das heißt wenn
der schwitzte dann sei aus wie ein Schaf
Carlos Valderrama hatte seine Haare alle
hochtoupiert und auch die Sachen auch
nach 90 Minuten noch ganz toll aus in
waren blond gefärbt und und in lauter
kleine Curlys aufgedreht er sah wirklich
aus wie ein anderen Pudel dann gab es
diese grandiose bulgarische Mannschaft
gegen die Deutschland der unglücklich
ausgeschichtet eine rockertruppe vor dem
Herrn in der Abwehr Tri von Bahnhof ja
es sozusagen der Realität gewordene
Klingone
der lag nie am Boden immer nur die an
warum eigentlich ja also das war der
hatte so eine so eine Holzfäller
Ausstrahlung der machte schon Angst wenn
man den sah ich habe dann später mal
gelesen sollen ganz netter Kerl gewesen
sein ich glaube nachher in Österreich
noch Fußball gespielt und ist leider im
Alter von 50 Jahren ums Leben gekommen
wirklich
schon damals Angst einflößend aus der
kolumbianischen Mannschaft erschossen
also wie ihr Lust da damals noch Fußball
war ich will das jetzt also das waren
schon gut dass heute ganz anders ist ja
heute ist alles ganz anders heute gibt
es nur noch Spieler die anschließend
sagen die habe ich nicht der Mannschaft
helfen kann also lieb und so nett ja so
demütig und so weiter ich meine Uli
Steiner der 86 Suppenkasper zu
Beckenbauer als als Bundestrainer ist ja
also ich meine
ich war doch schon schöne Zeit als Mann
wenn man so sozusagen den Hang zum
unmittelbaren Wort hatte und keine Angst
vor Klischees ja das auch äußern konnte
das war und dass ich das heute eben so
in Richtung entwickelt hat dass das
alles so stromlinienförmig geworden ist
also ich denke immer die Fußballer sind
heufer häufig so zugeschnitten wie die
Frisuren die sie haben und deswegen habe
ich mich auch sehr gefreut wir haben mal
drüber geredet als Toni Kroos ja so
deutliche Worte gefunden hat und ich
finde das einfach gut aber noch ein paar
andere letzter Zeit ja ich finde das
auch wirklich gut ja oder mertesackers
ja also Mertesacker grandios her ja nach
dem Spiel gegen Algerien ja und sagte
was er denn wollte wer da keine
Karnevalstruppe gegen die sie da
gespielt hätte genau sie ist immer wenn
das Wort Karneval feldtürchen passiert
irgendwas ja genau also 94 USA ich fand
die WM irgendwie groß und die Lust habe
ich fand es damals schon irgendwie nicht
schön dass Sie da so in football Stadien
gespielt haben und so das war so für
mich als alter fußball-romantiker war
das nicht schön aber ich würde ich
könnte jemanden anderes stallvorlage
anbieten sag mal zu dem was Fußball
auslösen und das ist ein heiß
umstrittenes Thema WM in Argentinien 78
ja
sagen und hat man nachher auch gesagt so
was darf nie wieder passieren 78 wie
dela geschrieben faschistische Diktatur
an jeder Ecke da haben die die reiche
Oberschicht hat die Kinder der Leute
adoptiert die in den Gefängnissen zu
Tode gefoltert wurden und zwar ein
kinderlose Familien wenn die nicht
erzählt wie ihre Eltern waren und so
weiter grausig und da hat man obwohl man
das alles wusste 78 die WM stattfinden
lassen so und ich habe das als
14-Jähriger so wie ich erzogen worden
war schon als maßlos skandalös empfunden
und gedacht das darf doch nicht wahr
sein und so weiter jetzt gibt es Leute
die sagen du weißt nicht was diese WM
argentinien hat ja auch gewonnen
ausgelöst hat in Argentinien es war ein
Triumph der Straße gegen die
militärdikator es war nicht der große
Prestige Erfolg wie dela darauf weg dann
kam noch caillieri der Falklandkrieg und
dann war die Militärdiktatur zu Ende ja
also gesagt das Ding ist doch eigentlich
ins Gegenteil ungeschlagen es sollte
eine Propaganda Veranstaltung sein und
es wurde eigentlich ein Sieg des Volkes
in einem Staat wo man von oben dran
saniert wurden ich bin nicht in der Lage
das abzuwägen und zu sagen was ist
richtig und was ist weil man ja auch
nicht weiß was am Ende daraus erwächst
ja sag mal das eben nicht weiß und
deswegen ja die spannende Frage wird was
in Katar erwachsen oder nicht und ich
bin da nicht so richtig optimistisch
ich habe halt immer das Gefühl also am
Ende ist Bildung der Schlüssel zu allem
du kannst ja also wenn du wenn du wenn
es dir gelingt als als als Diktator als
Regime deine Leute einfach doof zu
halten dann hast du eine Chance
aber wenn du das nicht kannst und ich
glaube in einer Welt die immer weiter
zusammenwächst wird das immer
schwieriger
irgendwann brechen sich diese Kräfte
Bahn hast du gar keine Chance bitte mir
sicher speziell diese sehr junge
Bevölkerung die Hoffnung
das kann man egal wie repressiv man ist
ist es sei denn du bist Nordkorea ja
dann dann schaffst du es aber auch durch
geografische Lage an Land einfach so
komplett abzuschirmen dass die Leute
wirklich nicht wissen was da draußen vor
sich geht aber was ich feststelle auch
wenn ich wenn ich so meine Reisen auch
nach Afrika und so weiter denke es wird
zunehmend schwieriger die Leute einfach
für doof zu verkaufen das und sie dumm
zu halten das glaube ich weil die Leute
eine Idee davon haben was im Rest der
Welt vor sich geht und gerade junge
Leute also ich habe diese
Hoffnungslosigkeit gesehen bei jungen
Russen beispielsweise schon 2018
sie sagten wir wollen hier weg wir haben
wir unterm blutet zum Land ja auch
irgendwann mal aus und der erste Reflex
von unserem Regime ist ja immer gut dass
die gehen gut dass die gehen ja genau
dann sind wir ein Problem haben wir ein
Problem weniger haben ein Problem gelöst
weißt du der Punkt ist auch die Leute
die die Kinder dieser 300.000 Katar ist
die das Sagen haben wo studieren die die
Leben in London die studieren in Paris
die sind in Italien die sind sonst die
haben mir sehr klare Idee davon wie die
Welt noch sein könnte und speziell die
Frauen haben eine Idee davon wie die
Welt und das Leben noch sein könnten und
deswegen bin ich da ehrlich gesagt
ziemlich optimistisch dass ich auf Dauer
Dinge die so repressiv sind das ist
nicht zu halten okay ja dein Wort in
allersohr in dem Fall ja und dann hoffen
wir dass der agentinien-effekt ja von
dem ich gesprochen habe 78 dass das auch
ein
qatar-effekt wird das darf ich noch
einen Gedanken wenn du gerade sagst in
allersohr
wir darauf weißt Sebastian Sohn sehen
nämlich nach der Sendung mit ihm ein
Gespräch noch ganz kurzes Gespräch
gehabt die Frage Schwule Lesben
Homosexualität ja wir
bringen das ganz ganz häufig in die
Diskussion und werfen den denen das dann
vor und sagen pass auf Wiesen die
Situation von Schwulen und Lesben und so
weiter und so fort und was ist wenn ein
schwules Pärchen dann über die Straße
geht und und und was kann dann alles
geschehen erwies mich auf etwas sehr
Interessantes hin und sagte weißt du wie
verengend diesen Diskurs immer viel zu
sehr und zwar genau auf diese Situation
schwul sein oder lesbisch sein aber er
sagte es ist eigentlich ein eine
religiöses Thema ein in dem Fall ein
islamisches Thema
überhaupt der Austausch von von
Zärtlichkeiten von Küssen sozusagen
bringen Öffentlichkeit in der
Öffentlichkeit und zwar eben nicht nur
zwischen Homosexuellen sondern auch
zwischen heterosexuellen ganz
grundsätzlich das ist ein Thema wo es
gilt sozusagen mit einer gewissen
Feinfühligkeit in so einem Land
reinzugehen das fand ich sehr
interessant also der Punkt wir verengen
das immer sozusagen genau darauf ein
Wahrheit muss man das aber in einem
größeren Kontext einordnen
ganz interessant der Punkt den du den du
da ansprichst ist dass wir unsere Moral
ja immer gleichsetzen mit unserer
Sittlichkeit und was hier ist ist es ein
Land das hat eine andere Sittlichkeit
richtig und jetzt kommen wir mit unserer
Moral ja ohne uns über deren
Sittlichkeit Gedanken zu machen und dann
wenn man sozusagen diese kulturellen
Traditionen und Eigenheiten so in der
Handbewegung wegwischt und mit
moralischem Rigorismus das durchsetzt
was man vielleicht hier aus guten
Gründen für richtig hält dann ist die
Gefahr dass man mehr Schaden hinterlässt
als dass man gutes anrichtet immer
ziemlich groß genau ich fand es einfach
ein interessanten Aspekt einfach diesen
Gedanken mal mit denken ja und
gleichzeitig sich darüber im Klaren zu
sein dass wird er dann häufig auch
argumentiert das ist unsere Kultur wir
wollen das nicht das ist natürlich ein
Argument das nicht sieht weil sexuelle
Selbstbestimmung hat nichts mit Kultur
zu tun sondern Menschenrechten genau ich
denke wir sehen uns irgendwo beim
Glühwein und gucken uns bessere Spiele
an als Ukraine Schweiz 2016 ich danke
dir ich danke dir Markus bis bald
eine Produktion von m hoch 2 und p